you know what's interesting about you're
working on blackish now and you're very
funny very funny on the show and they're
probably people that don't immediately
think of you as being an actor that
would do comedy no not at all but you're
terrific and you seem to really enjoy it
I do I mean I black-ish is not the first
comedy I've done pee-wee's Playhouse was
yes
but the thing about that was when I
auditioned for it I actually went in and
did a whole sort of like serious sort of
like you know gunslinger kind of thing I
was like channeling mule brenner from
the Old West world movie right like he's
a serial he's a serious cowpoke and he's
gonna Keys it she's a gunslinger he's
gonna kill you and I'm gonna and I was
with John Paragon and Paul Reubens and
they were like lighter yeah oh oh you
mean like comedy yeah completely didn't
that's what someone said to us seven
years
no fooling heartstrings yeah we we have
a still here we found this picture of
you as cowboy cruising Buner go back and
look at those shows you II the peewee
stuff holds up here we stuff those home
really it was like the Batman stuff from
the sixties yes exactly
I'm a huge fan of that yeah we - yeah I
have looked at it it's probably been you
know eight years since I've looked at it
but it did you ever show any of your
kids like Mike look at Mike my young
daughter who is ten yeah
she had to she saw it she was like daddy
that's you yeah but I don't look
anything like that anymore and she was
like Teddy that's you so you know that's
sweet it's cool I'm always saying to my
kids when they see something of me doing
something in 93 like right does daddy
look older now and they're like oh yeah
drink too much